Are you looking for an immersive
musical festival that kills the competition?
Or perhaps a festival that pushes
the boundaries of the impossible?
Then welcome to Redwood Fest!
Yes, it's episode 7 of
"American Horror Story: 1984",
and Think Story is here with a
detailed breakdown, theories, and
what we can expect for
the final few episodes.
So strap yourselves in,
because here we go.
It's Camp ... Golden Star? in 1948.
That is the ugliest-looking beach ball.
Notice the white flag here, a totally different
logo and look than that of Camp Redwood.
You can even see it on the
uniforms the counselors have to wear.
And five cents for three licorice whips?
Brah.
But it's all made up for with the
introduction of a big AHS alum: Lily Rabe.
She's been in every season of Horror Story
except for season seven's "Cult".
In this season, she plays Lavinia Richter, Mr. Jingles' mother, who is also referred to as the Lady in White,
which is the title of the episode
named after her white nightgown.
Yes, that's Bobby Richter
alongside his brother, Ben.
Fun note, Ben named his son, the one in
Alaska, Bobby, in honor of his little brother.
Ben is a bit of a loner, preferring to stay in and
read comics than go out and play with others.
We also see more of this family dynamic,
where Bobby is treated well and Ben continually chastised by her mother for not being normal.
Lavinia has taken over as the camp cook.
She's a widow, with Ben's
father having died in World War II.
There's a fun nod to Bertie here as she's preparing PB&J sandwiches, just like Bertie did on the night of her death.
Bobby wants to go swimming, so
Lavinia entrusts Ben with looking after him.
What the ...?
We're here at the docks, where the campers
enjoy a nice day cooling off by the lake.
Ben tries to make conversation with some of the girls,
but he's about as socially awkward
as I am and they just bully him.
He catches sight of the lifeguard and one of
the counselors venturing off into the woods
and does what any boy
would do and totally pervs.
With his eyes on the wrong prize,
Bobby is left unattended and is
viciously skewered by a boat propeller.
Ben tries to warn the
boat, but it's too late.
Lavinia fumes at the counselors and
Ben for not watching after her son,
holding them responsible for his death.
This is almost identical to
the plot of "Friday the 13th",
Spoiler alert,
where Mrs. Voorhees goes on a killing rampage
because the counselors were busy having sex
while her son drowned in the lake.
Back in present day,
which for us is 1989,
Donna brings a fresh off death row
Brooke back to her hotel room.
We find out that Donna used baclofen, a muscle
relaxant, instead of the regular lethal injection
to trick the prison into
thinking Brooke was dead.
The detox, however, is so painful that
Donna has to tie Brooke up until it passes.
There's a fun little nod to Neil Patrick Harris, as Brooke watches him on the 80's program "Doogie Howser".
You might remember Neil as
Chester Creb in season four's "Freak Show".
Donna picks up some Jack in the Box,
please sponsor me,
and is told she'll be given a new
passport and identity now that she's free.
But Brooke isn't having it.
The last time she was with Donna five years ago,
she had her strung up as serial killer bait.
What's changed?
Well, Donna is looking for redemption.
She's seen the error of her ways
and wants to make things right.
She doesn't want to turn out like her father, who we
saw in the beginning of episode 5 was a serial killer.
Now, I don't know what you guys thought,
but when Donna conveniently put the ad for the
Camp Redwood fest, knowing Brooke would read it,
it made me think she's pulling
some sort of reverse psychology,
that she secretly wants Brooke
to come to Camp Redwood.
But hey, that could just be me.
When Brooke sees the ad,
she knows what she must do:
kill Margaret for the five years she spent on
death row and being framed for a murderer.
And Brooke didn't even finish her burger.
Donna takes Brooke to a
roller rink to let out some steam.
Hell, she's been cooped up for
years, might at least have some fun.
And we get a cheesy 80's style montage
of the two of them enjoying themselves.
They even have some licorice whips
like the boy ordered in the beginning.
Hey, and for someone who just got
off death row, Emma is looking fine.
In the back, however, is a character closely watching them, portrayed by AHS alum Dylan McDermott.
He's been in four seasons of the show: Murder
House, Asylum, Apocalypse, and now 1984.
Brooke reiterates that she's going back
to Redwood, nothing is gonna stop her,
when Bruce approaches - or at least
that's how he introduces himself to the girls.
On IMDb and the subtitles, his character is
named Alex, so he may just be using an alias here,
since we'll find out he's the serial killer that has
been plaguing women along the California Highway.
He tells them that his car
broke down - outside a roller rink?
And he needs a ride to
his girlfriend to the festival.
They initially say no, but when they find their
car doesn't work and he comes to save the day,
they offer to give him a ride.
And Donna, after waiving her "No Stranger"
policy, says the best line of the episode:
Damn.
In the back of the car, Bruce seems to be enjoying the devil's dust, and Brooke is immediately suspicious.
Bruce tells them an urban legend
about a guy who stalks cars in the night,
which is likely his way of telling
them that the legend is based off of him.
Brooke feels uncomfortable and
demands he get out of the car,
when a state trooper pulls up
behind them, asking if everything is okay.
Out of the blue, Bruce shoots the
officer and decides to get out of the car,
giving Donna and Brooke time to get away.
Let this be a lesson to everyone
out there: always pick up hitchhikers.
Jingles' copycat Wide Load - yes, that's
his actual name they gave his character -
is trying to take a piss, just
like he did in his first episode,
which I guess confirms
that ghosts still have to piss.
Jingles is ambushed by the other
pranksters who he thought he had killed.
We learn that Montana seems to be running the show, telling the others to save their kills for the big festival.
As we later learn when
Jingles is brought before the dead,
Montana's plan is to create a massacre so large
it attracts media attention from around the world,
specifically paranormal investigators who she
believes may be able to help break the curse
that has kept them trapped
on the Camp Redwood property.
Now the whole gang is here
except for Bertie - what gives?
Notice also that Ben's
younger brother isn't there as well.
The simplest explanation for that
is that he died before Lavinia's death,
which supposedly caused the
blood curse which plagues them all.
However, there could be a world in which it's actually
the spirit of Bobby which is causing this curse.
Jingles tells them that he has
come back to kill Richard Ramirez,
the man who killed his wife
along with countless others.
Unlike the other campers,
Ramirez has the devil on his side.
And that's how the blood
curse did not affect him.
Wandering montage!
I think one of the strangest
things in this scene is
when Jingles starts questioning the
ghosts whether they can feel pain,
almost like he's preemptively
deciding if he wants to kill himself
like he ends up doing
at the end of the episode.
Jingles learns that her mother has
been chasing around the counselors
because she hates them
for what they did to her boy.
We also get a flashback of the
first Camp Redwood Massacre,
in which Lavinia killed all
the counselors for revenge.
When Ben finds out what she did,
he runs away and is stabbed in the leg,
a wound which has caused his
limp we've seen the entire season.
Notice how when he's resurrected at
the very end that his limp is now gone.
Ben ends up killing his
own mother, surmising
Jingles is spared and taken to the
cabin where Lavinia lives in the woods.
The cabin also gives me the
shack from "Friday the 13th" vibes.
Jingles enters and finds a cup and
ball toy, which belonged to his brother.
Now, this is either a clue
that Bobby is still alive,
or it's simply a memento Lavinia
keeps to remind her of her son.
But my guess is the latter, since Lavinia tells
Jingles she felt the presence of her son in the 70's,
but was disappointed when
she found out it was the wrong son.
Lavinia appears, seemingly
with the power to teleport,
and this is the worst mother-son fight since
I told my mom I wanted to go to film school.
She's a total dick to Jingles, constantly
berating him for the death of Bobby,
telling him that every
day for her is torture.
She was somewhat dormant for 20+
years until Jingles took the job as janitor.
She spoke into Margaret's ear, a girl who
was already quite messed up in the head,
and pushed her over the
edge to kill the other counselors.
It was a double victory for Lavinia, because she got to
kill counselors while destroying the one thing Ben loved.
Ben tells her he's here to kill Ramirez, but Lavinia
doesn't really seem to care. She's still mad as hell.
At a traffic stop, Bruce rams the police
car into them and takes them hostage.
When Brooke wakes up, she finds
that he has tied Donna up to the back
and wants her to be
the one to run her over.
She can either hit the gas
or get her face blown off.
I know which one I'm choosing.
His motivations are much like
Ramirez's: to be remembered,
telling Brooke that he hopes to
surpass Ted Bundy's kill count.
Brooke outsmarts Bruce by smashing
the like button - I mean, hitting reverse -,
allowing her the opportunity to
steal his gun and shoot him in the leg.
Donna and Brooke tie him up
and Brooke goes hardcore,
cutting off his thumb so
he can never hitchhike again.
Remember, Bruce: Karma's a bitch.
Brooke is gonna walk the rest of the way to
Redwood and Donna decides to come with her,
while Trevor, Margaret, and Courtney work to put the finishing touches on the poorly coordinated festival.
Seriously, $1,000 a ticket? Who
would ever go to a festival for - oh.
Margaret keeps slinging the big dick jokes.
Come on, Margaret, #allsizesmatter.
When Limahl from the
80's band Kajagoogoo arrives,
you may have seen him in my "Stranger Things"
video as the voice of Neverending Story.
Check out that video if you have a chance.
Trevor ventures off into the
woods, where he meets Montana.
Remember back in episode two,
he referred to her as his soulmate.
So it remains to be seen whether Montana will
be using him for more than just his meat stick.
Limahl ends his neverending story when Ricky
comes to collect a deal he had made with the devil:
a superstar career provided
to him by Satan himself.
Courtney brings a gift basket to the
Kajagoogooers - Kajagoo - Kajagoose?
to find them all killed.
This is seriously gonna impact the festival.
And in our final scene, Jingles hangs
by the dock where his brother died,
when he's visited once again by Lavinia.
He tells her he thinks about Bobby every
day and reiterates his desire to kill Ricky.
If Jingles is gonna stand a chance
against Ricky, he'll need to kill himself.
Now, I felt the show could have done a
better job explaining how this all works,
but it appears since Jingles
owes a debt to Ricky and Satan,
if he were killed by them,
he would be gone for good.
But if he kills himself, he'll be resurrected at
Camp Rewood and become one of the ghosts.
Jingles feels that if he's going to stand the best
chance of defeating Ricky and protecting his son,
he needs to kill himself, resurrecting in
front of his corpse, ready to take on Ramirez.
That's it for this episode
of "American Horror Story".
Make sure to like, subscribe, and leave your
thoughts and theories in the comments below.
You can also follow me
on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next time remember,
Daddy loves you very much.